en el último vídeo vimos que el problema
no se reduce a que un solo banco quiebre
tal vez un banco quiebra se vence el
plazo de algunas sus deudas en este caso
el banco va tenía un préstamo del banco
ve que se venció no pudo liquidar estos
activos y después no puedo liquidar
estos deseos por suficiente dinero como
para pagar el préstamo y entonces el
banco a quebró y vimos como a partir de
eso se puede desencadenar toda una serie
de sucesos este activo el préstamo del
banco ve al banco a el que desató todos
los eventos tuvo que ser reevaluado
porque el banco a quebró y pues no
sabemos bien cuánto dinero le va a poder
regresar a ver por supuesto todos los
que le habían prestado dinero al banco a
tal vez por ejemplo el banco de también
le había prestado dinero al banco y
entonces aparece en sus hojas de balance
ahora todos los que le habían prestado
dinero al banco a tienen miedo tal vez
se depreció en sus activos y encima del
problema de los deseos del que todos
estábamos hablando encima estos activos
apestosos que nadie valora correctamente
tenemos este nuevo problema estos
préstamos que le dimos a otros bancos
que de la nada se deterioraron estos son
activos que muy probablemente no valen
lo que yo creía que valían entonces
tenemos esta situación el banco a acaba
de quebrar y ahora todos se empiezan a
fijarse en el banco c eso se refleja en
el precio de las acciones muchos quieren
vender esas acciones y empieza a bajar
su precio además el banco se tiene un
préstamo del banco efe y vamos a
escribirlo préstamo del banco efe cuyo
plazo se vence y como el precio de sus
acciones está bajando
nadie quiere prestarle dinero porque
dicen ah parece que tú eres otro banco a
yo no te voy a prestar dinero
nadie quiere darles capital ningún fondo
soberano porque vas a perderlo todo
porque compraría yo una acción por un
pesos y va a terminar valiendo
o sea porque tus pasivos son más grandes
que tus activos así es que nadie quiere
salvarlos y entonces tienes esta
reacción en cadena esta cascada de
eventos negativos todos los bancos
tienen miedo de prestarle dinero a otros
bancos y tal vez hayas leído en algún
artículo que el gobierno está inyectando
liquidez
el banco dice algo así como ok voy a
tomar algunos de estos activos del banco
y los voy a tomar como garantía y te
vamos a dar un préstamo incluso siendo
estos una pésima garantía el gobierno
está dispuesto a dar un préstamo se puso
muy nervioso y empezó a prestarle dinero
a todos a cualquiera que tiene permiso
para pedirle prestado dinero al gobierno
y no sé si te acuerdes pero el gobierno
extendió esa lista generalmente sólo le
prestaba a los bancos comerciales pero
el inicio de la crisis crediticia de
hecho justo después de que bernstein
colapsara el gobierno empezó a prestarle
dinero a bancos de inversión y a otras
personas generalmente cuando la reserva
federal le presta dinero a alguien esa
persona mantiene un poco del dinero y le
presta el resto a alguien más y así el
dinero entra en el sistema y hace que
aumente la oferta monetaria pero lo que
está pasando es que los bancos usan
estos cds como garantía para tomar
dinero prestado del gobierno y una vez
que lo obtienen no lo dejan fluir no lo
vuelven a prestar porque están pensando
la verdad la verdad no sé cuánto valen
y no sé cuál de estos otros activos se
va a echar a perder así de la nada
cuando se venzan estos préstamos más me
vale tener efectivo de otra forma voy a
terminar como el banco a entonces todos
están tomando dinero prestado pero nada
más lo están guardando no se lo están
prestando a nadie más
así es que ese dinero se está yendo a un
hoyo negro entonces cuál es el problema
aquí pues podemos ver claramente como la
quiebra de un banco puede provocar la de
muchos otros sobre todo si nadie está
dispuesto a prestarles más dinero y pues
decir bueno no es tan grave el único
problema es que todos estos bancos van a
quebrar pero quién sabe tal vez el mundo
estará mejor así porque no tendremos
todas estas personas que honestamente no
están haciendo nada pero no queremos
decir eso al final de cuentas si son
útiles los servicios financieros aunque
en los últimos cinco años casi no
estuvieran creando cosas valiosas y sólo
se han estado aplicando y aumentando el
riesgo en el sistema si son útiles pero
bueno dejemos esto a un lado
tal vez digas ok en el peor de los casos
todos estos bancos se van a la
bancarrota
son reestructurados pero regresan y el
único detalle negativo es que los
accionistas pierden todo su dinero pero
eso no está tan mal si no hay riesgo no
hay ganancia y justo ese era el riesgo
que sus acciones se fueran a cero pero
los bancos regresarán con un nuevo
capital y regresarán dentro de cinco
años con un nuevo dueño y tal vez digas
que eso está bien el problema es que
estos bancos no solo son una red de
préstamos de dinero entre bancos algunos
de estos préstamos son préstamos a la
verdadera economía algunos de estos
préstamos son a compañías que hacen
tractores o tal vez es para la
agricultura tal vez es un préstamo para
comprar las semillas de la cosecha del
próximo año estos son préstamos
canalizados a la verdadera economía y si
todos los bancos están nada más
guardando el dinero no se van a hacer
esos préstamos y esas compañías no van a
poder hacer una inversión necesaria como
comprar las semillas o termina de
construir la fábrica de tractores o de
otra cosa que si tiene un valor real y
que todos necesitamos
todos nos vamos a morir de hambre y
vamos a entrar en una recesión horrible
porque aunque haya una forma buena de
emplear ese capital si tú le dieras un
préstamo a alguien ellos podrían usarlo
para crear cosas valiosas como construir
una fábrica o plantar semillas porque
aunque hay una buena forma de emplear
ese capital si tú le dieras un préstamo
a alguien ellos podrían usarlo para
crear cosas valiosas como construir una
fábrica o plantar semillas nadie les va
a dar el préstamo esas semillas no se
van a plantar esa fábrica no se va a
construir los granjeros van a terminar
despidiendo sus empleados al igual que
los que iban a construir esa fábrica y
como te puedes imaginar la economía se
va a caer al fondo eso es lo que tiene
muy preocupados a paulson y al gobierno
aunque algunas personas dirían que ellos
están más preocupados por los bancos que
por la verdadera economía y sólo la
están usando como pretexto pero bueno
qué es lo que quieren hacer al respecto
pues el medio del asunto son estos
2 billones de pesos en sede o
residenciales si la gente empezará a
valorar los un poco más si tan sólo
estos 2 billones de pesos en los libros
se pudieran convertir en 2 billones en
efectivo no habría problema porque
cuando se piensan estos préstamos si los
cede os valen 2 billones entonces todos
los bancos tienen un capital positivo y
no sucedería la reacción en cadena
cuando salió el primer plan de rescate
financiero y dijeron vamos a crear un
fondo con 7 billones para comprar
algunos de estos activos tóxicos y al
principio dijeron vamos a comprarlos a
un precio de rebajar nos quedamos hasta
que maduren y así hasta podemos ganar un
poco de dinero
yo dije muy bien pero eso cómo va a
solucionar la situación porque si fueran
a comprar esos cd2 sería muy tonto pagar
dos millones por ellos si el mercado
solo paga mil millones porque pagarías 2
billones de hecho esos 2 billones están
basados en suposiciones del 2006 cuando
se creía que los precios de vivienda no
podían bajar y todo el mundo estaba
pagando sus hipotecas y todo
completamente color de rosa
si pagas 2 millones de pesos por este
activo claro que salvaría al banco c
pero esencialmente estás comprando algo
que vale mucho menos y aunque lo
guardarás hasta la madurez
definitivamente no vas a obtener un
valor actual de 2 billones así es que
cuando escuché por primera vez la
propuesta de rescate financiero pensé
van a pagar a precio de remate pero eso
no va a servir de nada supongamos que
solo valen 10 centavos por cada peso si
pagas el 10% de estos dos billones si el
gobierno llegara y comprará a 200 mil
millones este activo aunque
probablemente el mercado los compraría
100 mil millones ellos tendrían que
reevaluar estos como 200 mil
millones
hay 200 mil millones y eso es 1.8 menos
de lo que decían que valían y entonces
van a tener menos 2.8 billones de
capital y de todas formas se van a ir a
la bancarrota de todas formas este banco
va a quebrar y otra vez se va a provocar
toda la reacción en cadena esto es lo
que el gobierno dijo las palabras
exactas de bernanke no vamos a comprar a
precio de remate vamos a comprarlos a
precio de retención hasta la madurez
entonces para mí lo que el gobierno está
diciendo es pagar suficiente dinero por
estos activos como para que los bancos
sigan con un capital positivo y puedan
pagar sus pasivos y podrías decir que no
es una mala idea pero yo digo que es una
idea terrible porque si estos valen 100
mil millones de pesos y tú estás pagando
2 billones por ellos
esencialmente estás dándoles un cheque
del gobierno por 1.9 billones de pesos
digamos para hacerlo más simple que esto
realmente valen cero y que el gobierno
paga 2 billones por ellos
el gobierno está básicamente escribiendo
les un cheque por 2 billones de pesos a
los dueños de las acciones de la
compañía el verdadero valor del capital
es de menos un billón pero el gobierno
les está dando 2 billones para que
tengan este billón de pesos
que creen que tienen y bueno también
está beneficiando los dueños de los
bonos porque si estos valen cero no sólo
van a dejar sin nada a éstos sino que
estas personas solo van a poder cobrar
tres billones de los cuatro billones que
les deben porque sólo hay tres billones
de activos así es que si el gobierno
paga dos billones por estos en realidad
le está dando un millón a los
accionistas y un billón a los dueños de
los bonos oa las personas que prestaron
dinero a la compañía y esas son las
últimas personas a las que el gobierno
le debería de estar dando dinero porque
son ellos los que prestan dinero que no
debía ser prestado son personas que
tomaron riesgos tuvieron todo tipo de
recompensas los últimos cinco años
y ahora cuando les toca sufrir las
consecuencias del riesgo que tomaron el
gobierno se pone a cuidar su bienestar
el bienestar del sector privado y eso
para mí es la peor idea
el gobierno dice yo sé que es una mala
idea y estas son las personas a las que
no queremos recompensar pero haciendo
esto sabemos toda la economía porque
haciendo esto evitamos que pase toda la
reacción en cadena y esperemos que así
los bancos sigan prestándole dinero a
los granjeros y a la persona que quería
construir una fábrica y a todos los
demás en el próximo vídeo pienso
explicar primero porque podría no ser el
caso porque incluso aunque les dieran
los 2 billones de pesos y aunque yo está
en total desacuerdo si funciona por
supuesto que vale la pena lo explicar
porque muy probablemente no va a
funcionar y también que hay mejores
formas de salvar esta situación formas
mucho más justas lo vemos en el próximo
vídeo